you've had a lot of scrutiny of your own
views and you're a member of an
Evangelical Church that is anti-gay
marriage and anti-abortion
um I just want to take a step back
um because you were brought up in the
Church of Scotland I think I'm right in
saying and then decided to join the more
conservative Free Church
what was your sort of thinking I guess
as a young woman what happened
well this is where the reporting has
been somewhat questionable to put it
mildly and I grew up as many will know
uh traveling quite considerably so I
spent eight years of my upbringing in
India incidentally there's no church of
Scotland or Free Church in India and
they have also lived and worked in
England for a while no church of
Scotland or Free Church in England
either went to University there and so
I've been a member of lots of different
churches and quite happy and content to
be involved with different churches
along the way and obviously having lived
and grown up in India I've always been
part of of communities where there are
different faiths I mean India is a is a
Hindu majority country with a huge group
of Muslims and it's always been my my
privilege to uh be you know to to have
friends close friends particularly
growing up in local Indian schools with
of people with it with lots of different
faiths and no faith
so given that you are as you say exposed
to all sorts of different religions and
different churches in your youth what is
it about the Free Church that attracted
you that Drew you there
it's not a trick question it's just down
the road
yeah I know it's just down the road so
um it's the it's the closest church I've
always been
um Keen to uh support the church that
was on my doorstep and as some of your
viewers may know and there is a little
bit of a Highland lowland divide in
Scotland when it comes to so it comes to
churches so uh the Free Church if you
really want to know has its roots
um in being a in ensuring that um it was
the local people that had the power and
there's been a long history in in the
highlands of Scotland which is where I'm
speaking to you from of of the Free
Church
I mean forgive me you're obviously
someone who's religion and your faith is
really important to you into your life
and all of those things of course and
you're ex you really are saying that the
reason that you chose the church that
you're with now is just because it was
down the road there must be more to it
than that surely
I I hate to disappoint you but um and
obviously welcome to visit the highlands
but a a having having lived I lived just
near Dingle and it is the church I mean
I've not made any uh sort of not made
any effort to hide my faith in the six
years that I've been in Frontline
politics indeed all my constituents know
um about my faith and yet they have
elected me uh on both occasions with an
increased share of the vote as somebody
they believe that will represent them
faithfully and without prejudice and
obviously over the last three years I've
been in perhaps one of the most
important jobs in government delivering
budgets for all of Scotland's people so
my Approach would be to say look at my
track record look at how I have
approached serving all of Scotland and
make your minds up about how I will
continue to do that because I would
certainly be focused on delivering for
all of Scotland